revirement au mexique un mandat d'arrêt
a été émis contre l'ancien procureur
général du pays jesús morillo il est
accusé de disparitions forcées de
torture et d'entravé à la justice pour
la disparition en 2014 de 43 étudiants
cette arrestation survient au lendemain
de la publication d'un rapport de la
commission denquête responsable du
dossier elle qualifie cette affaire de
crime d'état et puis quand les forces de
l'ordre elles-mêmes chaque résident
la promotion il y à une anciennement une
collusion dit il mais la participation
de différents niveaux de gouvernement
avec les policiers digoin soixantaine de
policiers de militaires ont aussi été
arrêtées
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 septembre 2014
43 étudiants d'ailleurs dit anna dans
l'état de guerrero sont arrêtés par la
police locale en collusion avec un
groupe criminel ils sont tués puis brûlé
dans une décharge les raisons restent
obscures
seulement trois corps sont retrouvés
la première enquête officielle menée par
ipsos mori youn attribuer aucune
responsabilité aux militaires elle
conclut avec un cartel de
narcotrafiquants s'était attaqué aux
étudiants cette hypothèse jugée entachée
d'irrégularités et de zones sombres a
toutefois été rejeté par la famille des
victimes et experts indépendants
l'enquète contreversé a repris 2 0 après
l'arrivée au pouvoir en 2000 19 du
nouveau président de gauche en bresse au
bras d'or qui promet de découvrir la
vérité
chez à celle de linde est
échec artiga le responsable d'eelv cache
non ça sera bien sûr la sphère n'est pas
close dit il le bureau du procureur
continuera d'agir la mort des autres
étudiants n'a jamais été confirmée bien
qu'aucune preuve ne laisse croire qu'il
soit toujours en vie ici daniel k jaws
radio canada montréal